[Music]
hello and welcome to chest open to
playing I'm Caleb Denby and they'll be
taking you through a line of the
advanced care of on so this is going to
see the sheer out of attack so this game
was played between Hikaru Nakamura and
ebony varios way back in 2007 well back
when hong Carter was young and full of
fire so the game of course opens up b4
c6 d 4 D 5
so we have the caro-kann and then Wyatt
opts for the advanced variation so now
these days a lot of people are trying
out this move directly in the move 3
which for a while that wasn't the most
play move by far the most played move
was Bishop f5 because after c5 Black has
to make sure that you can justify
spending 2 moves
playing C 6 and then right after he
lives instead of playing it in just one
move and that can sometimes be difficult
for him so we multiply move as much
above five and after Knight c3 we're
entering the sheer L variation so this
move seems a little strange right
because when you have this one structure
sometimes you want to play c3 to support
your pawns and a lot of times when the
karo you end up playing c4 to break down
this d5 pawn and this advanced line but
uh White has a very good purpose for
playing Knight to c3 which we'll find
out soon so after g6 White's next move
might surprise you if you're not too
familiar with this opening so what why
it wants to do now that black is
committed to e6 is take advantage of
blacks Bishop so in a different line of
the caro-kann which you reach
complaining Knight to c3
this move just defending your pawn Saudi
takes e4 Knight takes e4 bishops have
593 so already you're attacking this
bishop and then here white plays h4
trying to trap the bishop and take
advantage of flex early placement of it
so black usually has to play like h6 and
after something like that F 397 h5
Bishop h7 that's the other line that's
the classical variation in the Cairo but
here obviously it's a little different
because now if you play h4
black might just respond to h5 instead
and I mean the pawn structure is
different and you don't have an ID on g3
so everything has changed
so in this case what actually starts
with the move g4 driving the bishop back
to g6 so now if white boldly continues
with age for what might black do to stop
white the tech right in this tracks
right off the bat
yeah h5 so why is this move so good
right it's giving it's giving your
Bishop asked where you're getting space
on the Kings side and more importantly
it's going to force white to make a
decision
so if white decides okay I don't want to
trade my Jeep onto your H pawn I'm just
going to push forward he gives up a very
important Square and you guys know what
square that is well this square is not
so important right and you haven't
really given it up because f3 at some
point can defend g4 even though like
that move looks very terrible but blacks
not trying to make use of the g4 square
but especially in French structures and
Cairo structures the square is always
very very important yeah f5 so before g5
on g4 you're attacking f5 and White's
future plan was to play f4 f5 shutting
out this bishops and attacking blacks
weaknesses but after g5 something like
97 controlling the e5 square and white
is never going to be able to break
through so how can White prepare this
move h4 so what can white do to make
blacks h5 less effective but okay let's
take a look at this position ah let me
get rid of these arrows for you oh I've
just added more okay so what piece would
white like to have supporting this this
structure and where would you like to
have it
yeah so this night and where's the best
square for it
f6 well that's a little ambitious but a
more attainable goal might be f-for
right so if this night could get to f4
here it would attack this Bishop and
this pawn simultaneously so black
wouldn't really be able to take because
after night 66 you'd have triple
isolated G pawn which is never really
any belen favorite structure so because
of this white plays Knight G e2 here so
today we're going to be going over
blacks most popular response which is c5
and the past Black has tried moves like
f6 and 97 here but by far the most well
respected move with c5 let's we're going
to stick with so now after h4 black
still responds h5 and then uh what was
White's idea with nigt to
right so we're going to continue was
night up for now like I said H tix g6
would not be very good right because
after takes takes and takes blacks just
losing just immediately so black does
have to solve the problem of this bishop
so what can he do to prevent night take
g6 from winning the game it's not the
most natural move yeah that's right so
we're just going to come back to h7 but
what's the drawback with this move yeah
that's one and so that leaves the sage
pawn attack twice and defended zero
times so I can actually just take it so
black has gamma did his H pawn to give
us Bishop some safety and in the future
blacks hoping to take advantage of these
weaknesses that he has made as well as
some holes in this camp and especially
strike back in the center which white is
neglected by pushing over on the Kings
side so that's actually an old adage and
chest when your opponent attacks on the
flank you want to respond in the center
that's what blacks going to try to do
he's going to try to use the central
pawns to play so after Knight takes H 5
9 to c6 is what Barrios decided to play
and now how can white continue
so blacks making quite a big threat here
right so we might have to respond to it
the efficacy three is one idea but after
seat XD for you really don't want to
take back and end up with something like
this because uh well maybe black
wouldn't commit to taking back a second
time but this a paunch is going to be
weak and your bishop really doesn't want
to be on d4 as much rather be on g5 or
and one funny line even age six
the bishop travels to and on d4 it's
really not supporting your attack at all
I think actually Bishop III might be
playable though I think that might be a
move in this decision but most common is
what nakamura chose which is D takes T
five so giving keeping options for this
bishop open along the c1 h6 diagonal so
black recaptures and here white actually
plays Bishop to b5 so black obviously
can only take this pawn because these
pin to the King and you might be
wondering what happens if white takes a
free pawn so how might black respond to
this if thinking upon was check those
things kind of fencing
yeah King f8 and then the point is yeah
after something like Knight h5 the spawn
is simply going to fall so Knight 6 g7
might seem as though it comes with tempo
but after King f8 you're going to have
to move your knight back so you lose the
tempo again so instead white goes with
Bishop e5 and defending pawn and here
black plays the first move that's not so
popular so more often you'll see black
play Queen to c7 here simply defending
the knight and attacking the phone again
but after d4 this leaves white with some
options so rather than just moving the
night away Nakamura found a move that
was much better actually right queen up
three is the idea and now come our first
chose to take on c6 I believe followed
by Queen a screen so what is the idea on
D takes c3
ah right so after two takes c3 what did
you want to play yeah sorry I was Queen
takes f7 I'm not so sure that's the
funded twice right but yeah Queen Queen
c6 is the idea so here you're going to
have to give up your bishops check even
because you can't block because it takes
the rook so you'll have to play like
King f8 and then just cream c5 and
you're just totally lost so you can't
take this Knight so black decided that
his best course of action was to just
defend this pawn with Queen to d7 and
here Nakamura did not play the best move
Nakamura chose to play Knight to e4
which I mean this move is fine it
maintains an advantage for white but uh
what could be a better move here
it's not natural at all and I'll be very
impressed if you guys manage to find it
which move Knight b5 hmm I didn't
consider Knight d5 but I don't think
that's really making any significant
threats right just maybe rook b8
obviously I can't take it but rook b8
could just solve my problems and you'll
have to move your knight again the idea
is to sacrifice this Knight
so what can we do that makes a bigger
threat then a D takes two three well
actually it doesn't even all right this
is a little too difficult but I think
I'll just give you the move so it's
Bishop g5 here which you might be
thinking well what does that do at all
what if I just take the take the knight
which is actually black stuff move so
here the idea is your 2d one you'll
actually will take on g7 first I
apologize and then your kitty one so now
you have some serious problem so do you
know what happens if you move the Queen
away
what's White's threat
yeah 1986 so if Queen b7 for example
night 66 King d8 and Knight takes e5 and
as black it's just completely losing
like you can't defend this position
something like Queen c7 and just even
rook to d7 and the game so you can't
move the Queen away this much you can't
do so instead black plays PTAs b2 which
is kind of a funny move just leaving the
Queen completely hanging so on rook 67
blacks planted shoes make a new queen
out with the old and in with the new
right so how can white I keep the
initiative going continue making threads
because right now you're nice hanging
and you're down a piece so you
definitely need to play quickly here
right if you take the Queen right ah
so b1 equal screen and what's the plan
here rook to d1 alright and what if I
play Bishop b4 check I think King e -
all right so Queen takes a 2
and I take d6 well I've just I've
defended that yeah
yeah this is what blacks hoping for
that's right
so if you just Castle here then again
you're threatening to take the Queen and
you're threatening Knight to e6 and your
other rook will defend on b1 so the line
you have to calculate though which might
be a little confusing is b1 equals Queen
here so how can white just win after
this which Queen do you take for example
yeah you just take on d7 so at first
glance you might be thinking oh well
blacks winning a rook or something but
yeah this is just over once you move the
Queen away or take on f1 maid it's just
unstoppable on f7 so that won't work so
yeah now black is just losing because
you can't stop all of these threats at
the same time so best is to actually
play Bishop to e4 to distract the Queen
and then moving the Queen away and you
get some position where now of what
white actually does have to save the
night but he's won upon I think yeah
he's wise up one pawn this pawn on v2 is
probably going to fall and blacks going
to have to work very very hard to get
these pieces into the game and keep his
King safe so this is just a completely
winning but I won't go any deeper into
this line because this didn't actually
happen in the game so after Queen of g7
instead of going for this kind of insane
sacrifice nakamora as I said just play
the calm Knight to e4 so here Bishop b4
checklist played Bishop t2 was played
and Bishop takes e4 was played so
Nakamura just recaptured but again he
missed a chance to better his position
that's what I was thinking so 96 g7 just
wins a pawn and it's king of fate and
this should take speak oh let's check
although it's sorry sorry okay first
we're going to play 96 so Queen takes c6
Bishop takes before check King 2
somewhere
King e8 and Queen takes e4 so for the
moment white is just up well one two
three pawns and black has really nothing
to show for it so I'm not sure why
Nakamura didn't go for this line maybe
it was a rapid game he just didn't see
it but instead he chose the lesser Queen
takes e4 so after some more moves rook
to d1 or k d1 trying to King side or
queenside castle by hand and the game
just continued and eventually I'll stop
here for example because the opening is
pretty much over and white is just up a
queen pawn out of the opening and
Nakamura did eventually go on to convert
this but yeah this was an example of
white holding on to this h5 pawn he took
a long time ago and blacks central
played not really getting him enough but
yeah Nakamura I did after works very
hard to convert this so one of those
other lines might have worked better so
just to recap what happened in this game
was um after black play d4 here it
allowed this nice tactic with Queen f3
and that's when the rest of the tactic
started to flow so black definitely
should have continued with Queen to c7
so you might be curious now that we know
that h5 is losing a pawn what if black
ops for h6 instead so that's the game
we're going to go over next so I can
just pull it up here
it's not a game I just showed some of
the line alright so here we start off
the same of course and after h 4 black
ops for age 6 so this used to be the
most positive variation like in the
1980s when the share of line was
actually very popular black was always
playing h6 instead of h5 because of
course that h5 line looks pretty
frightening just giving up a pawn in the
initiative
so here White's going to continue with
Bishop to e3 trying to combat black
central play and by threatening to just
take upon so black plays Knight c6 and
white goes ahead and takes on c5 and you
might be thinking well what about C
takes d4 and I don't think this is so
good for black after something like
Knight takes d4 when f4 f5 is coming
very soon and like a especially since
black hasn't played age 5 so this G pawn
can stay here to support the pawn so
white and black and side goes for Knight
to c6 and after D takes e5 Knight takes
e5 Knight to f4 bishop h7 just more
developing moves like Bishop e5 nine
back 56 and Queen to e2 so setting up
some threat along this file maybe some
sacrifices and after something like
Knight G to e7 and queenside castle
black actually is a very difficult time
getting developed so I think mines like
these are why this h6 line is falling
out of favor because black simply can't
get his pieces out so you might be
thinking well it's not so difficult to
get your pieces out you just play
something like Knight to g6 trade off
the knife and you're totally fine but
unfortunately you can't play Knight to
g6 because of this sacrifice so how
might white continue from here to make
good on his sacrifice
Yanis Bishop to g5 uh well actually
we're going to insert h5 first but
Bishop to g5 is the same idea I think
it's probably transposes well actually
Bishop f4 instead but it's all the same
idea you're just going to open the
e-file and put your pieces to attack
this for night and yeah black really
can't defend against this and the game
is just going to end shortly so because
of this a few times has been played
black opted for something like Queen
eight five instead and after some funny
moves such as like Bishop d2 or rip 2d
third sorry not worth to do through your
h3 white scores very well so this is
partly why h6 is in plate anymore
because it just gives white to free of a
hand to do every once in the center keep
its King side play and it gets pieces
out while black is very constricted
alright so moving along we'll look at
another line where black simply goes
wrong very quickly so it starts off all
the same and here after h4 instead of
trying h5 right away which is the main
line or h6 which is the old line black
instead decided to insert this move you
take d4 so this is like the third most
popular move for black after h5 and h6
it's always simply recaptures and now
after h5 the fun begin so how can white
keep his pawn breaks in play now that
black has attacked his pivotal G pawn
because remember we really don't want to
play g5 and give up this f5 squared of
black and we really don't want to play G
takes h5 because in play Bishop takes h5
and black is doing fine
Bishop to b5 and black will simply play
in 87
yeah Knight to c6 is no good but 97
should be okay that's right so black our
whites just going to ignore this threat
and continue without four so after G
takes or h6g four of course White's just
going to candy with f5 oh sorry
first we're going to throw in this move
that you suggested which is Bishop b5
just to put the knight on the square and
now we're going to continue with f5 so
you might be thinking well White's gone
insane simply hanging all its pawns and
you might be right because blood can
actually insert this move so now what
would happen on F takes G six of course
is your take h1 and if you play your a
kicked h4 well I can recapture with
check so White's best move is to just
simply move the rook away continue
sorting supporting this F pawn and then
black best play is to just capture white
sacrifices so now was the point of f5
how does the white continue here because
you really have something to prove now
yeah II six is right giving up a fourth
pawn out of the opening
so of course black will play F takes c6
right 9066 was the natural move and it's
actually been played quite a few times
but perhaps a little bit better as Queen
d2 and I'll explain why in a minute
so after Knight 66 Queen to e7 Queen de
to black has a very nice defensive move
here which is just simply Knight to f6
ignoring everything so of course why
does made a threat and what was that
threat
yeah just nice to see 7/4 king king and
rook so white will accept the rook and
black wall height as king away but after
Knight takes a8 and Knight to e5 it's
actually not so clear because White's
nidus traps and black has some very
dangerous King side pawns so play might
continue something like Bishop a4 Knight
to f3 check King to d1
and black has ideas of playing something
like h5 our Bishop h5 Knight to e4 and
g3 and this is a little bit unclear
black certainly has some play here which
white of course should be better being
up a full rook but it's definitely going
to take some technique so a better line
for white might be Queen to e2 right
away so black will try to transpose by
applying Queen to e7 to just defend this
pawn and now White's a white zinger
really comes in here so what can white
play to distract the Queen from the
defense of this pawn this is the pivotal
move
yeah that's right just Bishop g5 giving
us the piece so of course if you play
something like tonight you gf6 I will
just take your rook and we get a similar
position as to when the knight took on I
ate where White has a rook in exchange
for all of these pawns but this one is
quite a bit better for white because
first of all we don't have a night out
of play sitting on the a8 and we still
have plenty of threats along east 6 and
d5 and I don't think black spawns are
going to be enough here so black is
obliged to accept the sacrifice and then
how do we continue well not quite yep
that's cry
right so that's that's a very good idea
but it's not quite the right move
because if we take right away what is
black defense here
yeah just Queen to e7 when your queen is
tend to your King and black is going to
be escaping so you can win this piece of
course right away but so you're just
winning your piece back because remember
we sacrificed a bishop on g5 so this
isn't going to be enough for white when
you've already sacrificed all of these
three pawns
yeah Bishop takes first
so this draws the King out so when you
take on e6 black is forced to move his
King again and doesn't have time for
Queen to e7 so King to d8 is the only
reasonable Square for black and of
course white continues by taking on d5
so came to e8 is actually the only
reasonable Square for black because uh
can anyone find the win after King to ca
Queen takes g8 not quite quintic g8
might be in okay move but it gives time
for black to sort out his issues I think
so something like Queen to e7 check
again might be played when after say
King to d1 and Bishop f7 White's lost is
Queen so you would have to actually just
go in for this endgame here I think
instead of King to d1 you have to play
Queen b6 here just to trade Queens which
we definitely don't want with watch King
so exposed 96 here that move might win
but he does have Queen III check and
then there are some complications so
simplest is just Queen to e6 one after
King to b8 Queen to e5 check and after
King to ca now the point is 96 when we
have Queen c7 and queen to e3 check has
defended and black really can't stop
this if you try to play like Queenie 7 I
think just Queen side castles and there
are too many threats for your queen to
handle coming in on d8 and c7 along the
dark squares so black instead goes King
de 8 and we actually throw in one more
check and after the King goes to f7
how does white justify sacrificing all
these pieces because if we're not
careful black is going to develop this
Knight and height is king over on h8
behind all of this pieces
Queen d7 well that might fall into some
of the stuff I was just talking about I
think I would have to block with my
night clean d5 sheared away yeah that
seems reasonable I think it might
actually just end up repeating after it
came to e8 because we actually just came
from this position
right so simply Knight takes f5 when uh
if something like Knight to f6 the point
is a 96 check with a discovered attack
on the Queen so black is forced actually
to give up his queen after Bishop f5 rs5
Queen f5 Queen at size 9 f6 and after
something like Castle I know a lot of
pieces were exchanged there so let's do
a quick kind of material or even on
Knights even on these rooks so black has
a rope and a bishop and one pawn for the
Queen so this of course should actually
be winning for white and the one time
this was played in this correspondence
game between Eduardo sack Leone and
ratio Danielle Daniel Daniel Daniel I
don't know to speak Spanish but uh Roca
and white ended up converting this in
the end so I mean you can't really ask
for much more out of the opening besides
an extra queen so let's look at a game
where black does everything correctly so
in this game black does all of the
opening correctly and then only to find
out the white still has quite a bit of
play in the resulting middle game and
you have to be very careful so of course
we start same way and after H 4 black
ops 4 h 5 Knight up for Bishop h7 Knight
xh5 and here black plays Knight to c6
again black's idea is to counterattack
in the center while white is busy on the
Kings side so it continues with d65
Bishop c5 Bishop b5 Queen to c7 so if
you remember the nakamura game black
played the D pawn to d4 and got all into
a lot of trouble because of this Queen
2f to remove so queen of c7 is
definitely most played and this should
take c6 and black actually ops to
recapture with the Queen which again
this is the main main line and this
share of attack
and after Queen to f3 doing its best to
prevent this d4 push for the moment by
placing some pressure both along this
way with night six g7 + 96 ideas like we
saw and also keeping this Queen just
along this diagonal which could be a
little weak
so after king to f8 defending is G pawn
white ops to cast note white plays
Bishop e5 and after rip to see a white
obstacle King side so you might be
thinking well this doesn't look so bad
so black at all or you might be thinking
well this looks terrible terrible for
blacks I guess it just depends on your
perspective but uh black does have a
very convincing center with this d5 pawn
and eventually is going to push it to d4
and try to break through onto the C 2
square and but uh his issues are all of
these pieces it's going to be very
difficult for him to get to get these
pieces into play so white continues oh
sorry black continues with d4 just
trying right away to get everything you
want and here white plays Queen takes c6
or a take c6 so I'd say we're pretty
much out of the opening here and we've
gone into the middle game where White's
trying to keep these pieces restricted
and use his pieces to do something
useful in the meantime and blacks trying
to break through onto c2 so here a white
played a very interesting move which I'm
not going to ask you to find it because
it's it's rather difficult
maybe you there at home YouTube viewers
can pause the video and try to find it
but uh the problem is white doesn't
really want to spend the time to move
this night out of the way right now so
instead he brings his rook into the game
so this is actually a very powerful idea
so I'll ask you what happens on D takes
two three
yeah rook to d8 with oh excuse me with
Czech mates actually so black of course
cannot take this but he instead decided
to try to develop his Knight to h6 and
this was actually losing move which is a
it seems very odd because it's just a
natural developing move it's putting
pressure on this pawn but after this
next line which is very convincing
black just simply ends up in a much much
worse position so what do you think the
move is here well first let's both
identify some of the well let's just
identify what's going on
so black would love to crash through
this rook the only problem is there's a
deep on in the way right so white needs
to do is best to remove this deep on and
to do that
Yesi get rid of this bishop because this
bishops just going to defend this pawn
until the end of its days yep yes
they're just 98 for but now the problem
is Bishop takes you to with a fork so
how does white justify allowing this
fork yes so we'll start with 95 and
Bishop d1 up first yes sir we're going
to check for your session and press
forward but yeah so check first and now
well let's check so if Rick takes d1
King 67 what's the material account
yeah you're just down in exchange so
white once a little more compensation
than than just simply winning on d4
because after you take these four well I
can actually run with King to the kun
side and you still have to solve this
problem and you're probably going to
give black times solve his problems on
g7 by playing something like f6 maybe
sacrificing a pawn but getting rid of
his weak pawn in the process so we need
something better than or could be one
here 97 check you have the almost the
right idea so we would like to take more
pawns before we give up our night right
because you know if you have a couple
pawns for the exchange it's not so not
so difficult but all night g7 I think
black can just take here and we get a
similar position where we've simply done
everything in a different order we have
Mario has the right answer with Knight
to f6 check
so after takes and takes the check we're
winning the C pawn like you wanted to
play but we're just doing it with check
now so it's a little bit better
so after sorry
after King to f8 rook to d1 and black a
lot of problems here first of all if we
just do a quick count White has one pawn
for the exchange but really he is one
pawn a night in the rooks in the
exchange because black really really
can't get these pieces into play very
easily and for example King to g7 trying
to get their oak into play or takes here
and rook to c8 and after rook to d7 your
pawns are beginning to fall so White's
up to two pawns for the exchange because
black had to sacrifice this d4 pawn the
murders go to Zurich into the game and
he's going to win a few more as we see
so Knight 2 g8 again trying to get his
pieces back into play so after here rook
takes b7 Knight takes f6 G takes f6 can
you
we end up in the Sun game where white is
going to be up something like three or
four pawns through the exchange and
hopefully white can convert this so in
the game way way way way way back here
black was like huh I don't like that end
game for me so instead he played the
move Bishop to e7 trying to keep some
activity first pieces so after this how
can white continue should white respond
to this threat on this bishop sort of
should white just crash through through
d4 should white play something else like
c3 maybe yeah that one's that pawn for
the moment but the problem is after a
Bishop e7 q7 a g7 districts in the game
and you've allowed this knight to take
on g4 so those are two problems that you
don't really want to end up solving for
Europe on it yeah Dennis f3 that's an
interesting move so yeah the idea is to
just defend the pawn and ask like what
he's doing but I think the the next move
does everything f3 wants to do except it
activates your pieces a little bit more
yeah just for kicks t4 so of course this
depends upon sideways laterally and what
happens on Bishop take g5 for example
yeah you just take it and after night
2g8 blacks pieces have seen much much
better days and something like you're up
to d7 should be more than enough just
taking all the ponds or even you can
probably take time to defend c2 if you
want probably a lot of moves here moves
here are very good for white so instead
black tried Bishop take c2 and after
rook to d7 he has quite a few problems
so of course what happens on Bishop
takes a four yeah Bishop takes e7 and
then King to e8
well yeah that that's probably okay but
White has something stronger there
probably yeah so rook to d8 sacrificing
the bishop in exchange for the Turk on
h8 and up the exchange should be more
than enough for right
so instead black would have to play King
g8 and then just or take speed 7 picking
up the pond something like Rick to see
to trying to get activity and Knight to
f6 is a neat sacrifice when a black
really doesn't have much chance and a
none game like this because since pieces
he does have two pieces for one Rock but
the White has well after something like
XP to White will have three pawns for it
and his pieces are just very
uncoordinated and there's not much
chance of stopping these pawns from
leading down the board so in face of
this I think night itch actually
resigned here unless I'm mistaken yeah I
think he did resign here yeah I think
these are just moves I've inputted but
Dan stead of Bishop takes c2
well actually after Bishop takes t2
black could have tried something like s6
if you wanted but after gef sick or es6
gf6
and Ricky 7 you can't play King takes e7
because of Bishop f6 so F takes G or
takes b7 and again were threatening riff
to be 8 so you don't have time for
Bishop takes a 4 so it's something like
rook to g8 92g nice f6 or to g7 and we
get a very similar endgame or White's
going to have a lot of pawns and a rook
and exchange for two pieces so nigh
judge I mean sorry gulkin his opponent
probably calculated through all these
lines and just decided to throw in the
towel and resign
oh yeah very active play by white but
that's how you have to play in order to
score points of this opening you can't
be taking time to just like defend situ
or just move your night out of the way
you need to get your pieces into the
game to take advantage of flex misplaced
kingside so yeah
so something better for black might have
been Knight to e7 here in 79 h6 sorry
after 51 just Knight to e7 well now you
get a similar position after Knight to
a4 and white plays all the same
sacrificing moves but the difference is
this nice just on e7 instead of h6 and
it's just much better place - it can go
to d5 someday it can it's already get
all the way this rook to come into the
game it's helping the seventh rank a
little bit so yeah that would have been
much better for Vulcan excuse me so yes
that's another example of how black did
everything correctly in the opening but
the white still had enough initiative to
get a very nice attacking game and then
the last thing I want to go over for you
is a game of Peter stood loose look here
we're going to look at a different line
the black chose which is also totally
acceptable so we start with all the same
first moves and after h4 h5 night of for
Bishop h7 again sacrificing this pawn on
h5 black chose to take in the center
first whereas many of the games we've
looked at black has been playing Knight
to c6
so after takes and night to be 596
Knight 64 and Knight GED 7 ah white
again needs to develop with some
activity in order to restrain blacks
development over here so how can you go
about doing that
this should be five that's the move
that's going to come later I think
unless I'm mistaken instead we're just
going to play c3 just shoring up our
pawn structure so this is actually a
very interesting move because it's sort
of asking black what he wants to do
because black really can't spend time
doing things like this because it moves
like Bishop to b5 like Mario suggested
just taking advantage of the weak light
squares that's a special can no longer
defend and you still always have the
threat of Knight to g7 if you think
about moving the swish up out of the way
so here black decides all right you made
a waiting move I can wait as well and
plays a six so the idea is to just
prevent things like Bishop to b5 and
night to b5 so now white continues with
Ric to h3 which is kind of a strange
maneuver that you don't really see I
mean you see it in beginner games right
away of course when they play one h4 to
rogue h3 to get the rook into the game
but here it's a little bit more more
acceptable doping the work behind the
pawn and thinking about bringing it to
the center where it can attack the King
so black accepts the pawn on e5 and
after Bishop e5 Queen c7 stepping out of
the pen and York to e3 getting the wreck
into the game as I suggested black still
has some problems to solve
of course this Bishop on f8 is not
developed with rook on h8 is not
developed and there's some serious
sacrificial opportunities coming on e6
if this Knight ever decides to move
thanks to this rook on e3 so black
decides to play queenside castle
stepping out of the center and after
Knight to f4 again really putting
pressure on the c6 pawn black decided to
play Knight to c4
so here black or white has a decision to
make
because uh obviously a direct attack
this b-pawn is attack and if you move
the rook off of this file then these
ideas become very terrible and of course
it loses a piece to the spork so white
has to decide between a couple moves one
is Bishop takes e4 just taking the night
off the board and two is Knight takes c6
either night really so do you guys think
the knight the sacrifice on e6 is worth
it or not because these are either
questions you have to be asking yourself
because sometimes the sacrifice just
isn't working and you can't play
whatever you want and need to show a
little bit of restraint but sometimes
you need to realize that the time is
ripe and you really need to strike now
or else black simply going to develop
his pieces and end up with a better
position you just want to take the
knight yeah that's right so on Knight
takes c6 like this is just not working
at all so this is one of those times
when you have to realize after Knight
takes c3 I mean your queen isn't text if
you just recapture after takes takes and
something that's supposed to clean - b7
you just you have no pieces left you
like you can't always just be playing
the moves that a strike you as
interesting or attacking because
sometimes there's just nothing there an
actor like 968 Queen takes d8 for
example ah Black is just up a piece and
white really has nothing to show for it
so so there of course play the mature
move just Bishop takes d4
so black has the threat of course of e5
so white stopped it by playing Queen to
e2 and here black flipped up a little
bit with his next move
he played Bishop to b3 so this move off
the right off the bat looks pretty bad
because you're you know I can take this
and then take a pawn for free
but a blacks idea was to play e5 as
we'll see so after it takes d3 and e5
you have some more problems to solve as
white so first of all if you just move
this night away what is black going to
try to do
right that's one way but fortunately our
queen is still defending square it's
nothing spectacular but uh yeah he's
just going to break the pin exchange
rooks and play something like nice and
c6 and this position is totally fine for
the moment white is up upon but it's
going to be very difficult to keep track
of all of your team site pawns after
something like f6 and Bishop c5 and yeah
black just has a totally fine game here
so it's fiddler instead decide to
sacrifice his peace with queenside
castle rather than let black escape with
a relatively okay endgame so black
excess the piece and white recaptures on
d4 so black trades pieces because he
doesn't wanna get checkmated so white
trades again and black plays b5 to try
to give this King some space so now we
really need to play accurately because
we've sacrificed a piece and we don't
have too much material left to do some
check reading with
yep d5 um well yeah rook 54 is
threatened pending the king to the Queen
and it also gives the King some more
flight squares and some lines but uh
yeah it is kind of a strange move
yeah well eventually white is going to
try to do this but I think so they're
through in Queen to e4 instead trying to
take advantage of these newly weakened
delight scores after b7 was pushed to b5
so black has to stop checkmate somehow
because after something like Bishop to
f4 Queen to eat a ape is just going to
be devastating
so he played Queen to c6 trying to trade
Queens and this was kind of a bailout
because now White has an option to trade
into an endgame
so the endgame occurs after Bishop takes
d7 Bishop takes e7 sorry not be sure to
take c7 for black fish take c7 for white
black throws in Queen takes e4 rook
takes e4 fishy 67 and rook takes e7 and
what White has to do now is the side of
this endgame is worth giving up his
initiative for so that line would win
his piece back and you would have a rook
endgame where white might be able to win
you guys are leaning towards trying to
keep the initiative with tactical
solutions like earth to d8 or Quinn to
d3 preparing or to d8 but the Fiddler's
actually opted to just go in for this
endgame because after vertex H for f3
White's going to win a second pawn on
the Kings side and black actually
resigned here it's just technically
winning but I'm not actually 100% sure
on all of these moves
I don't think rook to the 8th is winning
because simply King to c7 started King
to b7 would be better and black might be
escaping and
after something like queen DD 3 which
was more along the lines of what I was
suggesting as an alternative black can
probably probably end up escaping here
in some town for example
hmm well this is actually kind of
difficult maybe just uh Queen to c7 here
no not going to c7 yeah it's tough
but alright maybe I'll try something one
night to g6 and how would you like to
continue from here c4 Wow okay so I'll
develop my bishop
okay so I'll recapture
and yeah so sometimes your tech just
fizzles out right I'm not saying that c4
is best maybe white has something better
here like her to d8 but so you do have
to be very careful so the fiddler
spotted that this was just a winning
reckoned game and decided to trade into
it and yeah like I said you didn't even
have to show his technique because black
resigns instead of facing the Sun game
after f3 yeah you have to know when to
treat your initiative in and to cash out
for an endgame or some other type of an
advantage material or otherwise those
are all the games I have for you today
this again was the shear of variation in
the karo con
[Music]